holy sequel Batman Batman versus
two-face this is probably the first DC
animated film that I unabashedly was
looking forward to and did not feel like
I had to reserve my enthusiasm for in a
while and it didn't let me down I loved
Batman return of the Caped Crusader's I
thought that was just an absolute ball
and a terrific love letter to the 1960s
Batman TV show and Adam West Batman in
particular and I was very sad when Adam
was passed on and then became
wonderfully relieved to find out that he
did get to complete his voice work on
this film before he passed away so we
were going to get this and we now have
it um I will be upfront about the fact
that I don't it's not as good as return
of the Caped Crusader's for a couple of
reasons the first is that it it's
lacking the newness I mean that's a
weird thing to say about a film that is
so deliberately being retro but there
was an inherent novelty to return at the
Caped Crusader's whereas here the
novelty part has worn off now thankfully
the actual comedy chops and the
deliveries of the lines and the
animation style is all strong enough
that even without the novelty it still
works but it does have a little bit less
of an impact without that novel factor
still being present even setting aside
the novelty issue it's slightly weirdly
structured because we basically get a
pre-title sequence giving us a history
and the origin for this version of
two-face and then we get over the course
of the opening credits more or less a
montage of him battling Batman over the
years and then as the story proper opens
two-face is kind of out of commission
and doesn't factor directly into the
story for a while now once he does the
the reason why the thing was structured
the way it was makes sense but while
you're watching it every time something
starts out being like okay but it's
still not two-faced that we're dealing
with
it feels a little weird but talking
about to face William Shatner was a
really good pick and not just for the
camp value I know it's it's easy to pick
on Shatner but you know what Shatner
there if there's one thing the man
really does it is commit and he commits
to this he's not phony at and he's not
just lending his voice so people go oh
it's Captain Kirk no he's committing to
this and it both in a serious level of
delivery in terms of distinguishing
Harvey from two-faced in his voice work
but also he embraces the camp penis he
knows what movie he's in and he works
really well and he plays off Adam West
very well Adam West again is wonderful
Burt Ward is terrific Julie Newmar comes
back again and as before is a little bit
of the weak link and I I meant to look
this up whether or not she's really done
voice work aside from this I get the
feeling that she hasn't there's just
something about her delivery that says
you're not totally comfortable doing
this are you but there are some other
ones thrown in there Lee Meriwether
shows up which for fans of the Batman
60s material it was a wonderful treat
because I think I didn't catch her voice
right off but then something happens in
the plug out of my I betcha that's Lee
Meriwether and then it plays along I'm
like oh yes it is so that was really
cool there's some really fun other nods
to things even outside me there's a ton
of Batman Easter eggs as there were last
time but there's other Easter eggs as
well there's like a whole sequence with
with kind of a biplane and they're using
the music from from North by Northwest
when the plane and with from the
crop-dusting scene in that I'm like oh
good that's great and it's not like
going out of its way it's background
music like it should be so it's not
going out of its way to you know throw
that reference in your face but it's
there for whoever picks it up but if you
pick it up that and a ton of other stuff
it's just wonderfully great fun and
that's just that's what this is this
what the first one was that's what this
is again I've been
I've managed to not talk spoilers which
is an odd thing cuz again it's not a
particularly surprising story but I mean
it has some twists some terms and it
what about some things in a way that
surprised me at a few points so I didn't
want to spoil stuff but much like the
previous one it is fun it is funny it is
exuberant it knows exactly what it is
and it is a love letter to this specific
vision of Batman so if you love or ever
loved or and thought you grew out of it
I bet you if you revisit this you'll
realize maybe you didn't that 60s era
Batman this is wonderful material and it
does make me sad that because of Adam
West's passing we aren't gonna get more
I mean I suppose it's not impossible I
mean they could get a sound-alike but it
it wouldn't be the same so like I I
guess part of me kind of hopes this is
it but between this and the other one
these are these are gems little gems of
animated movies that are you know
they're you you have to be dialed into
the phantom you have to have an
appreciation for the specific vision of
Batman and if you don't I'm not sure
there's a ton for you here aside from
just some well-executed comedy but it's
not gonna connect to the other way that
connects with me but if you have any
level of affection at all for that take
on Batman all the stars just it's
wonderful and it just smile smile from
end to end from the minute it start
until it finished and I did watch
through the credits just to watch all
these characters do the bat to see
because yes yes I'm gonna watch that
heck yeah so those are my thoughts on
Batman vs two-face
that's uh that's it for this one have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that's
available on Apple podcast as well as
stitcher radio I am also one half of the
punch like a girl podcast that is a
presentation of the fire and water
podcast network Fire and Water podcast
comm links for all that stuff is down in
the description until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]